it doesn't really matter if we're
married it doesn't matter if it was
potential
the law is what the law is the
constitutional rights of a child
you know are far more paramount than the
constitutional rights of a sexual
predator the laws that are being passed
are not making anybody safe
authorities say that california has the
highest population of registered sex
offenders
they could be living right next door to
you a sex offender a predator right
there on your doorstep
megan's law requires convicted sex
offenders in california
to register their names home addresses
and other personal
information on an online registry it's
supposed to make people aware of
dangerous sexual predators
in their communities i was convicted of
a 288
c1 which is commonly known as statutory
rape
the lewd and lascivious acts with a
child
this man is on the registry for
statutory rape
he chose to remain anonymous to protect
his family so
we'll refer to him as joe joe is stuck
on the registry for life
even though the alleged victim of his
crime just so happens to be
the woman who married him my parents
found out
about us being together and
my mom decided to press charges it was
all consensual and everything
she was a minor just shy of 16 at the
time her then boyfriend went to jail and
had to register as a sex offender for
being with her
but they stayed together and even got
married when he was released
it was actually illegal for me to be
anywhere near her for three years
but she waited for me and i waited too
the situation might sound
extreme but it's not that uncommon
there's two consensual teenagers that
are having sex perhaps 19 and 15 a 19
year old boy
that 19 year old boy could go to prison
and remain on the registry for the rest
of his life
janice bellucci is the california state
organizer for reform sex offender laws
now
california is one of only four states
with a lifetime registry
and bellucci is trying to help offenders
who she believes shouldn't be on it at
all
you can be put on the registry because
you urinate in public
children have been taken to jail for
sexting and they can be put on the
registry
data from the california department of
corrections shows that chances of a
registrant reoffending
are extremely low 95
of the people on the registry never
recommit a sex offense
it's just asinine that the laws are
what they are these days somebody on the
registry is being treated like a leper
and nobody wants to be around them
nobody wants to touch them
nobody wants to you know be in their
presence breathe the same
air that they're breathing joe and his
wife have to deal with non-stop
harassment from
those who see him listed on the registry
i don't know if they're going to send
somebody out there to
kill us they did send somebody out there
to beat me up
we had to put a temporary restraining
order on a neighbor
while joe and his wife feel that their
punishment is too harsh and undeserved
law after law continues to be passed
only making things more difficult
mission viejo is the most recent of many
cities in orange county adopting tougher
measures for california registrants
this year crimes against the child is is
unforgivable
councilwoman kathy schlicht introduced
an ordinance banning sex offenders from
public parks and beaches without
permission from the county sheriff
it was passed unanimously we're not
thinking from a logical and rational
place
instead we're acting from fear there's
always been stories
especially this summer about child
predators in the area
so it was like there isn't any
need to further study the issue let's
move forward
and it's always terrible when a child is
assaulted there's no doubt about that
but the fact is we need to be very
careful in the laws that we pass
we need to be surgically precise in the
laws that we pass
if there's a constitutional issue it
will be handled
you know through the courts of law but
in the meantime let's get the
legislation or the ordinance in place
most of these crimes are actually and
i'm talking about the sexual assault of
children
occur in the home this is true for the
very case that prompted schleich to
pursue the ordinance
about 10 years ago a child was kidnapped
and murdered
in orange county her name was samantha
runyan
she was abducted i believe from her home
this new ordinance combined with
previous california laws make it
difficult for
sex offenders to find anywhere to live
registered
sex offenders are not allowed to live
within 2 000
feet of a school or a park and so the
unattended consequences of that is that
a lot of them have become homeless
and so they are congregating in parks
because there isn't anywhere else for
them to go they can't live within those
areas
and then they can't go to the parks uh
was there any consideration for where
they would go after that
maybe they become prisoners in her own
home um
but i it's it's a law that
they that they have to live with anybody
who's been in prison when they come out
of prison
we want them to be rehabilitated and we
want them to be productive citizens
it doesn't make any sense and it does
not serve society well
for them to be jobless and homeless joe
and his wife now live in a trailer park
and joe hasn't been able to find a
stable job since he had to register
because they live in california joe's
status as
sex offender is permanent we're together
we're married he did everything he was
supposed to do
and it's sad to live this way there have
been some efforts to reform california's
draconian laws
this past january assembly member tom
amiano introduced a bill for a tiered
registry
what we have in california is a
one-size-fits-all
and it's very counterproductive if you
really want to effectively
uh pursue and prosecute the most
horrendous crimes you are cheating
that process by wasting
these very scarce resources and
enforcement mechanisms
opponents to the law worried that
reforming the registry would allow
serious sex offenders to slip through
the cracks if there was even the
possibility of getting off the registry
people are being timid around an issue
like this and
immediately think if in any way you step
up to the plate and say maybe we should
do this better or differently
that they would be accused of being
pro-sex offender what we are
asking our lawmakers to do is to stop
and think don't act from emotion stop
and think
look at who are the dangerous people
where do these incidents occur these
attacks occur
and let's you know let's target
legislation there
the lawmakers didn't listen amiana's
bill was defeated 41-19
and for now the registry will remain
clogged with relatively minor offenders
who face humiliation and threats every
day of their lives
i'm scared all the time i'm worried
maybe sometime in the future
there could be something that can be
done
possibly for our situation